i've been trying to make this argument
more recently
um and might write an essay on it is you
know people talk about the great filter
right and which is again this like
doomsday thing that you know people want
to say there's no aliens out there
because something terrible happened to
them um and it matters whether that's in
our in our past or our future as to the
longevity of our species presumably
which is why people find it interesting
but i think it's not it's not a physical
filter it's not like things go extinct i
think it's literally we don't have the
technology to see them
um and you can see that with microscopes
i mean we didn't know there were
microbes on this table for our tables
for thousands of years or telescopes
like there's so much of the universe we
can't see and then basically what we
have done as a species is outsource our
physical perceptions to technology
building microscopes based on our eyes
um you know and building seismometers
based on our sense of feelings like feel
earthquakes and things and ai is
basically we're trying to outsource
what's actually happening in our
thinking apparatus into machines now
into technological devices and maybe
that's the key technology that's going
to allow us to see things like us and
see the universe in a totally different
way but you kind of mentioned the great
filter do you think there's a way
through technology to stop being able to
see stuff so can you take a step
backwards i think so yeah did you imply
that with the great so like well no i
mean i think there's a great perceptual
filter in the sense that
a
a
example of life evolving on a planet
over billions of years has to acquire a
certain amount of knowledge and
technology to actually recognize
the phenomena that it is well that's the
sense i have
is uh
i mean you talk with physicist engineers
in general that there's this kind of
idea that we have
most of the tools already just to hear
the signal
but to me it feels like we don't have
any of the tools to see the signal yeah
i agree that's that's the biggest like
to hear we don't have the tools to
really here to see yeah
aliens are everywhere we just don't have
the the um yeah i mean well
oh that's i mean i got this in part
actually because you were like you know
that last time i was here was like look
at the carpet you know could it like if
you had an alien detector where the
carpet be aliens i mean i think we
really don't
i i would be both aliens would
nevertheless have a high assembly index
or produce things like high assembly
yeah yeah yeah and those things have a
high assembly index
uh you have to have a detector that can
recognize high assembly index in all its
forms yeah yes that's it that's it take
data
construct assembly space yes patterns
basically so one way to think about high
assembly index is interesting patterns
uh of basic ingredients
i can give you an example
because i mean molecules we've been
talking about in objects but we're also
trying to do it in um spatial
trajectories like imagine you're just
um like i i always get bothered by the
fact that like when you look at birds
flocking you can describe that with like
a simple boys model or like you know
people use spin glass to describe animal
behavior and those are like really
simple physics models yet you're looking
at a
system that you know has agency and
there's intelligence in those birds and
i and basically like you can't help but
think there must be some statistical
signatures of the fact that they're
those that's a group of agents versus
you know like i don't know you know the
physics example maybe like i don't know
brownie emotion or something um and so
what we're trying to do is actually
apply assembly to trajectory data to try
to say there's a minimal amount of um
causal history to build up certain
trajectories for observed agents that's
like an agency detector for behavior do
you think do you think it's possible to
do some like like voids or
uh those kinds of things
like artificial like cellular automata
play with those ideas with assembly um
with assembly theory have you found any
useful really simple mathematical
um like simulation tools that allow you
to play with these concepts so like one
of course you're doing mass spec in this
physical space with with chemistry
but it just seems well i mean computer
science person maybe it seems easier to
just i agree with you and sexier in
terms of uh tweeting visual information
on
uh twitter or instagram more importantly
to play like here's an organism of a low
assembly index and here's an organism of
a high assembly index and let's watch
them create more and more memories
uh and more and more complex objects and
so like in mathematically you get to
observe what that looks like to build up
an intuition what assembly index is like
we are building a toolkit right now so i
think it's a really good idea but what
we've got to do is i'm kind of still
obsessed with the infrastructure
required and one of the reasons why i
was pushing on
information and mathematics when human
beings
when human being we take a lot of the
infrastructure for granted and and i
think we have to strip that back a bit
for going forward but you're absolutely
right i would agree that
i think
the fact that we exist in the universe
this is like i can see there are lots of
people gonna disagree with the statement
but i don't think i don't think sarah
will but i don't know i don't know the
fact that objects exist i don't think
anyone on earth can just will disagree
the objects can exist elsewhere right
but they will disagree that life can
exist elsewhere but what perhaps i'm
trying to say is that the the
the acquisition the universe's ability
to acquire memory
is the very first step for building life
and
that must be that's so easy to happen so
therefore alien life is everywhere
because all alien life is
is uh those memories being compressed
and minimalized and the alien equivalent
of the cell working
so i think that we will build new
technologies to find aliens
um but we do not we need to understand
what we are first and and how we go from
physics to chemistry to biology
the most interesting thing as you're
saying between these two organisms
different assemblies is when you get
into biology biology gets more and more
weird more and more contingent where
physics is pro the chemistry is less
weird because the rules of chemistry are
smaller than the rules of biology and
then going away to physics where you
have a very
nicely tangible number of ways of
arranging things
and i think
assembly theory just helps you
appreciate that and so once we get there
my dream is that we are just going to be
able to suddenly are
i mean i'm i mean i'm maybe just being
really arrogant here i don't mean to be
arrogant it's just again i've just got
this hammer called assembly and
everything's nailed but i think that
once we crack it we'll be able to use
assembly theory plus telescopes to find
aliens
you